you know there's one sentence that I try
to describe Bridgewater meaningful work
and meaningful relationships through
radical truth and radical transparency
so meaningful work means we're in a
mission together we're excited about we
do we want to do it excellently that's
meaningful work meaningful relationships
are these relationships and where
there's the honesty helps you you can
argue things through but you always know
that there's honesty and that there's
Mutual caring for each other radical
truth means that knowing what is true to
be able to deal with reality whether you
like the reality or not but to know what
reality is imagine if you had a disease
would you want to know that you had that
disease or would you want not want to
know I'd want to know radical truth and
radical transparency means you get to
see everything that's very powerful need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
Nation Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn from
what Ray dalio and my take on his top 50
Joy
failure is a part of the learning
process right what's the risk of failure
what you'll be embarrassed or risk
affiliate how do you distinguish failure
from learning uh in your whole life you
know failure implies that it stopped
that the Game Stops right if it's part
of a you're failing and then you learn
then that learning is part of the moving
forward
right so that is what the process is
like fail learn move forward and
constantly do that because you're
cutting edge you're going where people
haven't been before in inventiveness so
pervasively we were talking about
culture
it is when people disagree and you you
can take thoughtful people disagree you
have then the potential of learning a
lot if if people who are disagreeing can
say why do we disagree and work through
that conversation in an intelligent way
to try to find out what's true you can
learn you can make progress it can be a
fabulous thing I believe that everything
works like a machine so when I when we
talk about markets when we talk about
economics you know how I think it's just
a machine
everything has cause effect
relationships and you can program all of
that we're at machines human brain's a
machine and we operate that way and then
today's age we have data we have a lot
of data and so to be able to look at
what people are like is a powerful thing
when I when I hear the interview about
General Motors and you think about one
country one company or another you think
of Tesla and by contrast okay look there
are two things that make a difference
it's either people or culture okay and
that's everything and so everybody's
talking about
this was done or that was done step back
what were your people like how are they
different
what is your culture like and how's that
and that's all that matters and so if
you look at it that way and you compare
what the future of General Motors is
going to be in the future of Tesla is
going to be or any such things that's
what all that makes up the difference
and you can put data together that shows
that and you can operate in that way and
that's what makes you effective
make sure you're actually taking action
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
what happens with meditation as you know
um is it's just a simple exercise that
allows you first to clear your head and
then brings
an Equanimity to everything everything
it eliminates the stress it eliminates
the emotions
um you're a busy guy yeah I I I've been
doing it for uh 44 years but I do it you
know twice a day probably a third of the
time once a day probably a third of the
time and not at all for 20 minutes twice
a day yeah 40 minutes a day as part of
your oh it's such a great investment I
would say that more than any other
factor of having any effect on My
Success it's been meditation because the
Equanimity and also the creativity
because it opens uh between the
literally the prefrontal cortex and the
amygdala it opens the two sides of the
brains and allows a spontaneity
creativity and open-mindedness and and
so it's good for the not only the health
because because it you get with stress
is a terrible thing but it also is very
good in terms of the clarity and you
don't get the emotional hijacking and
it's great for creativity so it's helped
me a lot it's the biggest gift I can
give everyone I'm 64 years old yeah
I don't want to have fears
fears of things that are being opened
fears of another I'm not going to let a
fear stand in the way of something that
I believe is valuable mistakes are good
things
mistakes are good things meaning if
they're made in learning in other words
so
mistakes are how we learn because
mistakes produce pain and if you produce
that and you convert that to learning
like for example punishing people for
mistakes
is bad because they hide things where if
you were to say to your kid and who
makes a mistake the only thing you have
to do is tell me what would you have
done different in the future and then
we'll be good that learns makes that a
learning process or weaknesses everybody
has weaknesses has a number of
weaknesses the great people that I've
seen in almost any area always have
weaknesses they just have known what
their weaknesses are and have ways of
getting around those weaknesses we break
it into two parts we have two basic
portfolios there is the Strategic asset
allocation mix which we call all weather
and that just has nothing to do with
bets it has to do with how to make all
the assets the same risk parity I would
call risk parity the problem them is
when people try to diversify and they
own some equities and equities has a
volatility right that's large or they
own assets that do well when the economy
does well and do badly when the economy
does badly they have a concentration of
their risk in in some assets right they
need to have they need to change the
portfolio they need to buy longer
duration bonds or leverage the bonds or
bring up so that bonds and commodities
and pieces have comparable impacts so
that whatever happens in the economy
will then have a bouncing effect because
the one thing you could be most
confident is that asset classes on
average will outperform cash okay so if
you have that's a strategic asset
allocation that's what the all-weather
piece is then there's the bets the bets
are zero-sum right in order for you to
beat me in the game you're going to you
it's like poker it's a zero-sum game I
have we have 1500 people who work at
Bridgewater we spend hundreds of
millions of dollars on research and so
on we've been doing this for 37 years
and we don't know that we're going to
win in other words we work that we have
to have Diversified bets we have a lot
of Diversified bets and so on so it's
very important for most people to know
when not to make a bet because if you're
going to come to the poker table you're
going to have to beat me and you're
going to have to beat those who take
money so the nature of investing is that
a very small percentage of the people
take money essentially in that poker
game away from other people who don't
know when prices go up whether that
means it's a good investment or if it's
a more expensive investment sometimes
the high points come from the low points
they're simultaneously meaning I you
know like I learned the most when I am
making mistakes and so I know like for
if I'm making money in the market it
might seem like a high point because you
figure okay you're making money but you
don't test yourself as much when you're
making a low point and you're in you're
saying how am I doing this wrong and
you're learning a lot or at least I'm
learning a lot first of all I have a
terrible memory
um I'm I'm very unreliable
um I I really I'm incredibly uh
forgetful I need people around who will
take care of a lot of things that I'm
for me in other words I need handlers
and people who are meticulous
and organized
and
um those are my you know those would be
the major I miss by the way I mean like
at any time I believe that I'm missing a
lot uh like I look at there's so many
things that I'm not seeing the one thing
that's good about that is that I know
that I'm not seeing them and so that's
why I keep going to other people who I
who I find see differently and that's my
biggest Advantage my biggest Advantage
is not what I know what I know is a
small percentage of what I need to know
my biggest Advantage is that I know that
I don't know a lot and I'm worried about
not knowing and that I know how to speak
to people who might know a lot and then
I and do have that process and then
through that I learn a lot and I
minimize my chances of harming myself
because I don't know that's that oh the
people who feel like they're I'm good
I've got it
won't learn if you've got it you won't
learn
right so so you have to get rid of this
ego barrier I've got it thing obviously
can you tell us are you authentically
satisfied and fulfilled do you have an
experience in life of being successful I
don't think that uh success is like a
lot of people uh believe it is and for
any really successful person I think
that um everybody's always struggling
and what happens is you know you just
struggle at a higher level it's like
learning how to ski or play some Sport
and you're just kind of doing this
higher thing but it doesn't feel like
that it just feels like I'm struggling
and I think it's um uh and and it and
it's a good feeling I I the way I think
of it is um
I've always thought that it's like in
order to be successful in life you have
to cross a jungle
or you could stay on the other side of
the Jungle and not cross the jungle but
if you choose to cross the Jungle the
jungle has all sorts of
things that can do your harm and bite
you and everything along those lines and
so the West best way to do that is to go
into that with people who can see things
differently and watch themselves and
struggle to make it to the other side
and then what I've discovered along the
way is that it's always a struggle and I
enjoy being in the jungle I don't want
to get to the undecide I don't want to
get out so that's what it feels like to
me every time I made a mistake they
became painful mistakes but with time I
realized that reflecting on those
mistakes would give me gems
um what I would do is I'd say why did I
make that mistake and I would learn from
that mistake and I'd write down a rule
so what was helpful for me is I put that
rule principles these principles I wrote
These principles down those principles
that I wrote down I then put into
algorithms in other words equations and
what I learned by being able to do that
is by if I took my decision criteria
those principles and then I tested them
back through time I gained a perspective
that was fantastic I could test them in
back a hundred years I could test them
in different countries and I would learn
how those rules work and I put by
putting all those rules together and
then how having these algorithms the
computer could replicate my thinking but
it could actually think better than I
could because it what it would do is it
would take you it could process more
information it could process it faster
and it could process it less emotionally
so it was like having a GPS that was
next to me while I was also making my
decisions like you're driving in a car
and you have both operating and to have
that next to me was you know invaluable
it would learn I would learn and
together we built that I think every
place has to have a culture right
right and culture is the values what
what values are living out and and so
for example this the number one value is
it has to make sense to you we have to
talk about it we have to work it through
in a non-egotistical kind of way
and so it's an unusual place and it's an
unusual culture
are you offended when people sometimes
label it a cult
I think that I think a cult when I think
of a cult it means believe this
and we're it's the opposite you take it
from on high in other words occult mean
yeah
somebody's telling you believe this
because I said to follow it because I
have a superior it's exactly the
opposite of that right the number one
principle is don't believe anything
think for yourself and now let's go
through a process of what is true
together
but we can't stop that with ego we can't
let that barrier stand in our way so
we're going to live in a culture in
which we can do that okay now that's the
opposite of okay it's it's a belief
system in other words I'll ask you do
you believe that we should operate this
way with each other
okay if you want to call that a cult I
think it's the opposite of a cult it
means think right speak up don't hide it
don't talk behind people's backs it's
talking behind people and you always
make a point that you know what you
don't know and that's equally valuable
more valuable
I want to say that
um
so this is the whole philosophy
I I so know that I can be wrong look we
all should recognize that we can be
wrong
and if we recognize that we're wrong and
we worry about being wrong then what we
should do is have a thoughtful dialogue
it's the mixture of the elements that
matter right yeah if you have a
tremendous tenacity but you're you're
studying you're learning you're trying
to memorize and remember everything that
you're being taught and you're really
trying hard you could have great
tenacity you need the making sense of
something you need to embrace reality
you need these other dimensions right so
the I think the things that we started
to talk about just before the you know
the things that these people have a need
for
is is first they need to most
fundamentally make sense of things which
is a very different kind of learning
process it's a very internalized
learning process it's not a memory based
process so none of these people unlike
the population whole none of these
people have a desire to follow
instructions for most people you you you
go to school they tell you what class to
go to
um they what classes to take this goes
all the way through University they they
do this do this to this and then you go
into the class and they say learn this
and this is the information and it's
largely a memory based instructional
based process this is not what these
people do right this is not so the path
what they what they have is a strong
strong desire to understand and make
sense of reality how does reality work
your company anticipated the financial
crisis managed your clients funds
through the that period
make the argument that your culture
actually has something to do with that
result well
first of all I think that
well I'll tell you what the the moment
was like we you do our calculations and
uh we have a view that's very different
than the rest of the world's View at
that time
so the independent thinking
we had among ourselves different people
who had different views and the ability
to work ourselves through those
um was essential for us to being able to
stand upside from the crowd so I needed
to have the independent thinking and we
needed to work it through and then even
at that time we had to have
um the fear of being wrong
because you can never be confident that
you're right in the markets and so to
place the bet but to place the bet in a
defensive way and to work out together
the engineering what what I believe is
that everything happens over and over
again
through history
World operates like a machine it happens
over and over again and that if you can
sort of go above yourself in your
circumstances and look down at yourself
within your circumstances within a
historical perspective and then have
agreed upon principles
you know principles are how to handle
things that happen over and over again
by having that it's helpful and ours are
just oriented around this idea
meritocracy so it allowed us to have an
independent point of view while being
not a hundred percent certain and you
know to be defensive and it allowed us
to play that well so the big shift in
terms of going to
um the notion of what do I do with my
money let's say you have a lot of
liquidity and you're look the world has
lots of liquidity today the world has
lots of liquidity the question is what
are its choices
and what do those choices look like and
then you put your money so you produce a
lot of money around a lot of liquidity
and then say do you stop buying U.S
bonds uh when you have or do you stop
buying uh Japanese bonds uh when you
have um
no interest rate and a currency risk
um and and so when do you stop buying
well it's when you have confidence in
some ultimately when it's driven to
something else at some point you get a
move toward inflation if there's a move
toward like I want to hold inflation
assets then you come into problems until
you don't have that move to move toward
inflation assets you have a capacity for
a lot of the buying there and it and so
the timing can you go to what you're
like can you go to your mistakes can you
go to your weaknesses
right can you go to other people's
mistakes and weaknesses some people
because of an ego barrier can't do that
and so if they don't recognize their own
mistakes their own weaknesses or others
mistakes and weaknesses what the root
cause me being what they're like because
of ego barriers if they can't go there
they're going to repeat those mistakes
they're going to have them over and over
again
so it's the process essentially of
saying at that stage what am I like
everybody has strengths and everybody
has weaknesses the weaknesses are the
other side of the strengths so let's say
if you're you know a right brain
creative person you may not be reliable
because just the way you think
necessitates you to think a certain way
that means you can't think in another
way that means you're going to keep
bumping into that thing that's standing
in your way but unless you can Embrace
I'm not reliable all right and deal with
it you won't get around it it's still
going to continue to be a barrier right
so the diagnosis to the root cause is is
important so then
if you diagnose it then you have to
design what are you going to do about it
that works
so
um let's say you are very creative but
not reliable okay you have to find the
means of it first of all embracing that
and then saying
um if I'm not reliable what do I do do I
work with a reliable person do I learn
reliability do I have some compensating
mechanism because I can't let that lack
of reliability stand in the way my goal
as long as I keep doing that I'm going
to keep running into problems so you
have to design what you do about the
problems and then when you're designing
what you do about the problems
then you have to follow it through so
you have to
follow through or or do the thing you
designed
um and and and the doing the thing you
um requires self-discipline and so on so
people have to do those things in order
to be successful right they have to know
what their goals are they they have they
will encounter their problems they have
to diagnose those problems down to the
root cause the real root cause they have
to design ways to get around them and
then they have to have the
self-discipline to follow that and it's
a continuous iterative process so that
that's what we keep doing right so
you're going in that direction I would
say that all of the Shapers are doing
that they're doing that
they're doing that well right so they
don't mind the problems they don't mind
that I think it's very important to know
what people are like
yep most organizations don't want to go
there
by knowing what people are like and
having them part of the process of
knowing what they're like there's better
understanding better communication and
also of course you can make better teams
because there nobody has all that's
needed to be successful
um you know we need each other to play
different roles and the ability to do
that by knowing what people alike is
enhanced you have no idea how you all
see things differently
that there's a thinking Spectrum some
people are creative and not reliable
some people are reliable not creative
and as you start to give people
personality tests like Myers-Briggs or
the big five or different personality
tests you start to learn how people see
things differently and then when you see
them differently and you and that screen
pops up wherever rather than just seeing
how you see it you go above that and
you're seeing that everybody is seeing
things differently it changes how you
see things because it starts to make you
think
um how do I know I'm not the wrong one
in other words as you go above it and
you look down on all those different
ways of seeing you start to think
how do I know I'm not the wrong one and
how do I collectively see and you see in
a color range it's like seeing in a
different color range or going from two
Dimensions to three dimensions all of a
sudden you see the full spectrum of
seeing things and then you go to the
higher level we have systems that go
through the computers that go the higher
level that say then how do we weigh all
those ways of seeing to make the best
decisions
so not so you don't get so attached to
your opinions I think the greatest
tragedy of mankind is people holding on
to wrong opinions that could so easily
be rectified and that's doing them hard
because they're making wrong decisions
so how do you collectively do that well
the answer is by everybody seeing
everything and seeing how others see
they begin to gain those perspectives
they also get to get an appreciation for
the other way of seeing it used to be
that everybody would drive each other
crazy you you your brain works in one
way my brain works in another maybe I
see big picture you see detail right
maybe I'm creative Unity you're reliable
we drive each other crazy when you start
to realize that people are actually
seeing in those ways and that's a valid
way of seeing and that I need you and
you need me and how to put together the
team as you're asking about it gives you
the evidence base it's okay to be
different I should explain believability
weighted decision making to you if you
sure if you're interested okay so
ordinarily
yeah there were two ways of making
decisions pretty much uh there's the
boss has control and so autocratic
autocratic I'll call that autocratic
takes in everything and then he makes a
decision
or there's Democratic pretty much one
man one vote
um but really the best decision making
is believability weighted decision
making and if you think about it first
conceptually
you would say if you're going to make a
decision of what you have medical
condition and you're going how are you
going to get that you're going to think
who are the best doctors Consulting
experts right consult the experts but
this one knows more and that one knows
less and how do you do it and then you
have this triangulation and then you
make that that's kind of the idea of
believability decision making we have
ways of assigning believability that we
all agree are fair that we each assess
each other and we get certain amount of
believability points
so now imagine that you had
believability your believability on a
subject matter maybe it's investing
maybe it's accounting whatever the
subject is that you have a certain
amount of believability weighted points
and you're together well those
believability weighted points uh when
you say okay what should I make as a
decision now I'm responsible for
something but I ask everybody else I and
I take a believability way to vote I can
have a believability way to vote when I
have that believability way to vote vote
I really do believe that it's going to
be a better decision than I would
individually make that's believability
weighted decision making so 19 a
1979 80 81 I calculated that American
Banks had lent a lot more money to
emerging countries than those countries
are going to get paid back and I
anticipate that there would be a debt
crisis and with that an economic crisis
so that was my thinking
um and august 19 1980 to Mexico
defaulted on its debt and a number of
countries followed and so because I said
that um I got a lot of attention about
that and I thought that was going to be
producing uh a bear Market in stocks and
I could not have been more wrong August
1982 was the exact bottom of the stock
market and I was wrong and as a result
of that um let's take my eight employees
or
um I had to let them go I lost money for
myself I lost money for and I had to
borrow four thousand dollars for my dad
it was the most painful one of the most
painful experiences but it was one of
the best experiences that ever happened
to me in my life because it it changed
my perspective about decision making it
made
um it may gave me the humility that I
needed and fear of being wrong in my
decisions while I was able to maintain
my aggressiveness so it changed my whole
approach to decision making the two big
things is how do you get your alignment
of your lower love you with your upper
level you how do you get past your ego
and your blind spot and we know what the
ego barrier is like I got to be right or
whatever it is or I'm not good at this
the blind spot barrier is the
realization that people actually see
things different they see different
things like somebody will see the big
picture somebody will see the detail
they'll focus on different things almost
like a color spectrum type of thing and
if you realize that you will see a part
of that spectrum and other people will
see the other part of the spectrum and
so that you really need to when you go
above yourself you really need to
orchestrate all those ways of seeing
because you are not just one of those
people that's got to do it yourself your
way of being the the success is to go
above it and be the orchestrator and
know what you're good at and what you're
not good at so it's almost like if you
want your life to be successful you will
not let yourself do certain things
because you're just no good at them once
you get that pick picture down then you
can find the pass wherever the paths are
you're open-minded because you now
you've given up your ego barrier and
your blind spot barrier knowing how to
adversify well is more important than
almost anything people don't understand
this is that an evergreen principle yes
that's an evergreen principle
interesting and the reason I'm saying
that the way it is it's almost like a
casino making it's money okay okay the
way that you do it is you get an edge so
now when you have to make a bet I've got
a bet against the whole world the world
has view on something is reflected in
the price
so when I think something is attractive
or unattractive that means I have to bet
against the whole world and whether
that's right or not that's difficult I
get it right you know more often than I
get it wrong but I'm going to get it
wrong sometimes and so when you can take
a lot of different bets what you can do
is like the casino you'll get your
average that your bet would be but
you'll reduce your risk of one of those
tables not being the table that's paying
off and so that margin that so I can
reduce my risk without reducing my
return by knowing how to diversify this
is like the biggest message that I think
that I would get a little across that
I'm trying to convey in principles and
so on
um is that
so many people in there have opinions in
their heads
that might be wrong and they're too
attached to them and if you know how to
um operate with a certain amount of
uncertainty and stress test your
opinions in a different way use get away
from your ego get away from all that you
can learn a lot about raising your
probabilities of being right so what it
made me want to do is find the smartest
people I could find who disagreed with
me and then I could have conversations
with them meditation is the biggest gift
that I can give anyone and I would say
more than anything it is whatever reason
for Success I've had because it allows
one
on back to the two U's I'll clarify what
I mean is that in your mind that we
think what do you want and the reality
is when you look at the neuroscience and
psychology that there are different
parts of your brain that want different
things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the logical part of the brain that
you're conscious of it's called the
conscious and you think you're being
logical and you want to make those
decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system part of the brain
which is the emotional and it's not as
conscious to you but it has more of an
influence on you than really The Logical
one and so they're not aligned and so
when you're experiencing that pain or
let's say the ego right there were two
main things you got an ego barrier and a
blind spot barrier if you can get past
your ego barrier and you get past your
blind spot barrier you can accomplish
anything because you'll also know that
you don't have to do everything to you
don't have to figure it out yourself you
can take in from other people the
different ways to approach things in the
best possible way and so the realization
that we all are really struggling with
ourselves and to think which are which
is in control meditation helps to deal
with the alignment of those two things
the average person who's listening to
many people think that they can go into
this very difficult zero-sum game of
betting against the consensus and be
right
you know what I mean in other words
investor says I'm going to go in the
markets I'm going to make money betting
against the consensus and be right right
because the consensus is built into the
price okay okay that's what's up so it's
think of it as like going to a horse
race and there's handicaps okay you're
not going to pick the best horse and
you're not going to pick the best
company
a terrible company can be a better
investment than a uh a terrific company
a terrible company could be a better
investment just like the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are changing like you go into that and
that becomes the long shot but because
the long shot is going to pay off 25 to
1.
right if he comes in
that you could just as likely bet on the
the long shot as the leader and it's
going to be equally likely that you're
going to make money right otherwise
you'd otherwise the market would be
doing the opposite well the market is
like that right in other words if
everybody believes that something's
going to be terrific okay then
everybody's betting on it and it's price
is high
so it's not what's best necessarily it's
what's best relative to what's in the
price what's discounted you now use a
lot of computer related algorithms to
help you navigate the market yeah you
know algorithms are what we call them
today equations is what we used to call
and so you would write that down and
what I learned is by being clear then I
could tell how that decision would have
worked in the past in all different
environments so it gave me a lot of
perspective on making that decision I
could test it through the Great
Depression and so on and then I could
find that if I use that same algorithm I
could take data from and have the
computer make decisions in parallel with
me and so and that is what I recommend
for everybody I recommend they write
down their principles and then realize
that almost any of those principles can
then be converted into algorithms and so
the computer was making decisions in
parallel with me making decisions that
type of partner ownership between me and
the computer and also expressing the
algorithms was invaluable not only in
the quality of the decision making but
also the quality of the relationships
that I had with the people I worked with
my son in 2014 gave me a book by Joseph
Campbell called hero of a thousand faces
and basically he described that these
things happen you know everybody crashes
and then you're faced with uh that crash
and you either have an epiphany or you
don't
now you either walk off the field and
say hey I don't want to do this anymore
and you give up on that going after your
audacious goals or you gain really
humility you you know how do you feel
that you're going to be wrong and so I
think then that whole notion is
um you know to come back with the
finding the smartest people I could find
who disagree with me
um also I'm in the investment management
business that you have to bet against
the consensus
otherwise you can't make money because
it's in the price and you have to bet
against the consensus and be right or as
an entrepreneur I'm an entrepreneur I
had to bet against the consensus and be
right and so to gain that humility was
the the thing so you either get off the
field or you learn you have to know what
you're going after
um you can't have everything in the
world but you could have
almost anything you want but you can't
have everything you want if you go after
your goals and they're clear you have to
know your goals know yourself Follow
Your Passion make your work and passion
the same thing while considering the
money part because money will get you
freedom and choice and be able to make
that but if you know yourself feel the
pull and pursue that passion understand
on your journey your hero's journey that
you will have mistakes and you will have
weaknesses and to understand those not
fight those because by understanding
mistakes you will learn not to make
mistakes again I have a principle which
is pain plus reflection equals progress
so that reflection is important to know
yourself know your pulls know your
weaknesses and when you also know your
weaknesses and the strengths of other
people there are people who have
strengths where you're weak and you
upstreams where they're weak and to be
able to work well together is the most
effective way of achieving success then
you start your own company right yeah
and when incredibly well at the
beginning
1975 it was me a guy played rugby with
in my two bedroom apartment okay and uh
everything went well until it didn't go
well that's right and did you then have
to go borrow money from your father yeah
so yes so what happened was you know
um it was a very small company just uh
you know a handful of people and I love
to trade the markets and we did it for
institutions and then he
um and then in
1979 80 81 I calculated that uh foreign
that the American Banks had lent more
money to foreign countries than the
countries were going to get paid back
and um and I had its controversial world
view that the world you know is going to
be a big debt crisis and Mexico
defaulted in 1982 so very interesting
1982.
and um when they defaulted I got a lot
of attention and I thought we were going
to have a terrible economic set of
circumstances and I could not have been
more wrong it was exactly the opposite
in August when they defaulted another
country started to default it was the
exact bottom in the stock market and so
I had to let off everybody and I was
down to me and I
um you know I said to myself well am I
going to have to put on a tie and go
drop take the train in and go to Wall
Street and so on I couldn't bring myself
to do that
um and I I was so broke that I had to
borrow four thousand dollars for my dad
to uh pay the bills and this was the
best thing that ever happened to me I
mean painful but it was one of the best
things that ever happened to me because
um it gave me the humility I needed to
balance with my audacity and then I I
needed to understand how can I have the
upside without having the downside you
know how and then I understood the
portfolio construction and risk
management and so on so forth so that
was my bottom and that punch in the face
that experience was one of the best
things that happened did you pay your
father back and some point the four
thousand dollars plus he didn't want
equity in Bridgewater
he didn't ask me no I think he he was
smarter than that I think the key is to
think of reality as
you're given reality is reality and
think of it as working like a machine
they're a cause effect relationships
that make the realities around you okay
now if you go above yourself and you
look at that how does that machine work
and then how do I interact with that
machine to get what I want and you do
that with an Equanimity meditation also
helped me a lot yes I learned to
meditate uh very in many years ago and
if you if you have Equanimity and you
look at it above and you look at with
curiosity and you say oh I must not be
interacting well with at my reality and
how do I change it and how does it work
it's a very powerful way of approaching
life if I'm making a decision
um that that after I make the decision
usually or right at the time if I pause
and reflect and I write my principle
down in other words principle is sort of
a recipe what would I use to how would I
make that decision and what are the
criteria around it I find that I make it
much more clear it becomes clearer and
it applies to the next thing that comes
along it'll be that way because
everything happens over and over and
over again and I think people make the
mistake of looking at just the one like
it's the first one they have I don't
know they have the first problem of this
sort of the first child or whatever it
is and this has been happening plenty of
times and so if you have the principles
I found that that helped me think more
clearly about it and it helped me
communicate better like why and so over
the years over the last 30 years or so
that's what I I've done I did it
originally to communicate very well with
the people I work with you know I set up
my company and and it was very important
to have good communication and then we
could debate the principles and so
that's the process I urge people to do
that there are many excellent decision
makers
um and I just wish that they wrote down
their principles when this set so for
example we'll be talking about Henry
Kissinger and his new book is going to
come out with a book on leadership
um and don't just describe the leaders
describe then what about them were the
Essential Elements to make a good leader
under what circumstances and so if we
think about that when then also then you
begin to think in a principled way and
then when you start to think in a
principal way life becomes uh it's so
much easier to make decisions and it's
so much less confusing because it's like
coming up on a species and you say okay
well what species is it not just another
it's a thing no what species is it and
how do I deal with that species
effectively and and so that's what that
is and so I encourage people to write it
down I wish anybody who's successful
wrote down their principles or their
recipes for making those types of
decisions in 1968 The Beatles went to
India and they meditated and then I I
heard about it and then in 1969 in New
York you could
um you can bring some flowers and you
could be that and you could learn how to
meditate and and wow I recommend it's
the best thing gift I can do it every
day or every almost ever almost yeah I
try to do it every day I try to do it
about twice a day and if I could take a
second to describe it
um
what it is is it frees your mind of
thought and it takes you from a
conscious State into your subconscious
and your subconscious is where
creativity comes from and Equanimity and
and all of that like if you're calm and
great ideas come to you and when you
have that Equanimity then you as you're
approaching everything things are just
the way they are and you have to deal
with them and it's a little like being
you know in the uh ninja movies it's a
little bit like being the ninja and
everything seems slower and you can
handle it better and so and you align
your subconscious which is where the
motions and also Inspirations come from
with your conscious mind and when
they're aligned and you have that
Equanimity it's a great thing I think
first of all one has to know their
nature
um
you might have to discover it but your
nature means do you have a sense of
adventure do you seek security are you
an extrovert and introvert those types
of things so personal Discovery is
important
um I think that uh who you're with
and where you are is more important than
what you do because in the early phase
of that second phase it's total
Discovery so it's experimentation you
know you went to India for three years
right yes and and that but if you have
that sense of adventure to let go you
can discover that's your opportunity but
discover yourself as well as to discover
what the choices are like and then as
you move later into that you'll feel the
pulls
um and to feel never trapped we were
talking just before we began that so
many people say
um you know I can't be that way because
I my job won't allow it which is a silly
concept because you have the freedom of
those choices even in when you have
constraining uh situations so I think uh
that's the life Arc
enjoy this wide open choice you can be
anywhere in the world you can do almost
anything let go experiment and then move
on to give the knowledge uh teach a man
how to fish is better than to give him a
fish I mean I think you can give them
both you can give education and you can
sure but uh ability the the capacity to
be productive because you know if I can
give you the capacity to go out in the
world it's like go into a jungle I give
you a knife and can you live in the
jungle okay if I give you that capacity
that's the best thing I can give you
that's why I wrote the book and you know
pass it on I wrote those principles over
years and I wrote them down and that's
what I want to pass along that's the
most important thing yeah but but if you
but if you've got money you can help
people a lot in a lot of different ways
which is thrilling what would you say
then are are the three greatest skills
that people that aren't financially
abundant or that are struggling
financially should learn to master in
order to be in a better position
financially three skills what would you
say they should learn well as I said
before I remember watching the movie I
was young David Copperfield with WC
Fields and he speaks to David
Copperfield and he says he said
something like and I'll put it in dollar
terms you're at a hundred dollars and
you spend 105 dollars
that's misery
if you earn a hundred dollars and you
spend ninety five dollars you'll have a
good life
I mean it wasn't exactly like that but
it was but but basically
I know so many people who don't earn
much but are there because if you start
to think about what it is that it costs
you to live in terms of let's say the
basics you know uh give me a bit to
sleep and give me the food let me be
educated and so on so forth
I think most people can get themselves
in a position
where you know they're not positive so
if you can be net positive and you could
do that that you know that's
number one
uh you know as I carry that so that's
you know that's number one then I guess
it was the list that we went to you know
the second is you know what do you do
next
in terms of what do you need what do you
invest in you know and then and then you
know going Beyond it and then there
avoid the following mistake the most
common mistake of investing thinking
that the investment that did good
is a good investment
people rather more expensive
the things that quite often
those markets that did really really
well became more more expensive and
everybody smart money is all the time
compete comparing them and competing
so what happens is
um the naive money
buys the thing that was hot or is hot
the thing that has been terrible which
might be the thing that's beaten down
so I would say also an important element
okay so here's another one that's really
important diversify
um so don't put all your eggs in one
basket right because what I learned
about this
is that first of all all Investments
uh compete and it's not easy to sell
tell whether one investment is better
than the other because if people could
do that life would be easy and everybody
make a ton of money
um so and this is a competitive game
that's very difficult to compete in so
it's very difficult to say which one's
better or worse you could take experts
and you could and do all sorts of tests
and you'll find out that they can pick
that and you can't tell whether the
worst ones are going to be better so
because of that you understand that um
even picking the best ones is difficult
and particularly if you're naive like we
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
each year on Research to try to give us
an edge okay now you've got to compete
with us so uh competing in the markets
is more difficult than competing in the
Olympics you wouldn't think I'm going to
compete in the Olympics but there are
more people who try harder
in order to do that so it's a zero-sum
game so but diversification
um that they're different uh will reduce
your risk without
um reducing your return yeah so if you
know how to diversify well
so
um that's critical so I would say again
uh get get your savings right and the
reasons I say I would say
um have great humility about what you
what you don't know don't buy the thing
that was hot just because you think it's
hot
um and then know how to diversify well
that those would be the most important
things I could convey know your goals
um know what you're going after
um you could have almost anything you
want but you can't have everything you
want and so you have to prioritize and
you move in that direction
on the way to your goals you're going to
encounter your problems and your
obstacles
so identifying now step two is
understanding your problems and your
obstacles identify them step three is to
diagnose them to get at the root cause
of the problem
and that could be many root causes but
it could also be your weaknesses or
weaknesses of others but you have to be
objective about them once you diagnose
them then you go to step four which is
to design a way to get around them
uh and then after you have that design
you implement that design so you have to
follow through and do it and you do that
and and that will then produce its new
results which should be better results I
have I call this kind of the looping
process it's the evolutionary looping
process and
um you do you just keep doing that and
you learn over a period of time and you
move in the direction that you want
there were three things that happened in
my lifetime that are happening now that
didn't happen in my lifetime before and
that I needed to study and that was an
enormous amount of creation of debt and
the monetization of that in a financial
piece
the second is the internal conflict
populism of the ride and the left
that and with wealth gaps and so on that
I like to measure things that you'd have
to go back to 1900 to see those degrees
of conflict which I think are a threat
to our system and a democracy and could
produce a civil war type of situation
and third the rise of a great power to
challenge an existing great power in the
existing World Order now those three
things in their degrees individually but
also collectively last time they
happened was 1930 to 45 period And so
when I when I needed to do was to
understand those patterns and those
things and I took it into it and so what
I'm hoping to show is simply the
mechanics of it in a lot of and then
explain why it appears that we are in an
important juncture now what we do at
that juncture so yes it's measured and
and there are the United States is in
relative to decline in my measures which
are measured and China has been rising
and that's an issue but that doesn't
create necessarily A Destiny it creates
a situation which I hope we can we'll go
through that I want to distinguish
there's big differences in opportunity
yes so let's say supposing you have two
people of comparable opportunities yes
and then they were going to do that okay
the marshmallow test yeah as you as you
know apparently is you take a kid and
you say okay uh you can have one
marshmallow now or you could have two
marshmallows in 15 minutes if you don't
eat the first one yeah if you don't eat
the first one right yep okay once you
start to realize
that deferred gratification
is going to make you better and so on
and you start to count count and you say
like something like how many
days weeks months or years can I live
if I don't have money come in and you
start to focus in on that
that's the first step okay like the
marshmallow test okay so I want to save
you got to start there then if you do
that
you're necessarily going to go save in
what
and then you'll start to get exposure
to
how these things are different
okay then you start to care I can have
one of these and one of those and you
start to experience
and then you start to learn
and basically that's what makes the
difference once you have a fear that you
might be wrong but you have still the
audaciousness and courage to go forward
you're a lot smarter than the person who
thinks they know there's a quote that
Jefferson said he who knows he knows not
is closer to the truth than he whose
mind is filled with falsehoods and so
when you know that and then with your
character and your determination you go
forward the smartest people I know are
the most humble what the more you learn
the more you realize oh I'm eager to
take in so that's right and I would say
that there are many people in your
audience who can plan for a simple
lifestyle that can be wonderful
sometimes we acquire these needs that
aren't at anywhere near as big as as we
make them out to be do you have a bed to
sleep in do you have food to eat do you
have basic health care okay if you start
to think okay what are my needs that I
really need and I'm okay and how can I
make Provisions for those needs then
once you've got that in your mind you're
free okay you you can go beyond that
that you may say listen oh I can do that
for a year or two years or a month or
whatever but you I think we visualize
too much
the things that we're used to one of the
good things about this exercise is that
you can bring it brings you back to
basics you can be brought to Basics and
like I'm saying if you have a bed to
sleep in and you've got food
and so on and you have those Basics and
and good relationships with people who
care about you and basic health care so
if you budget for that and you figure
how do you have it maybe it isn't in the
luxurious
place you're in maybe it's in the
country and so on once you visualize
that and you get that down in your head
and you say oh I can get that
then your stress will disappear because
you as you visualize that in many ways
that's a happy life it doesn't take a
lot to there's stimulation there's
nature there's relationships these
fundamental
wonderful things the most important
things can be obtained and so for many
of you I think if you look at that and
you budget for that I'm seeing a number
of people
um who are
um going broke
uh and and I've watched this over many
years
and really it's just the adjustment
process when once they get to that point
where odd you know they have they get
settled
they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's your it's uh icing on the cake
so I want to emphasize you can budget
for that you can look at that find that
scenario
find what that looks like so that you
know you've got it down then you know
you're safe once you've got safe
everything beyond that is luxury
whatever success I've had has come more
from meditation than any other
thing any other influence and you and I
um no because you you're you're a
meditator your wife's a meditator we
meditated in your
um room your meditation room
um we know what it is and I'll explain
what it is
um
um it it I'll first explain what it
gives you and then I'll explain how it
gives you it gives it to you
um it gives you an Equanimity a ability
to almost rise above yourself and to see
things in this
um thoughtful way almost like uh a ninja
in a uh Ninja movie as things are coming
at them everything sooner seems slower
and you approach it and you can deal
with it in that way and it gives you
um a greater level of creativity and it
does that by uh connecting your
subconscious to your conscious it
achieves that by repeating a mantra so
here's how it works there's a sound that
doesn't have a meaning it's a sound we
could for example it could be something
like oh and mentally you repeat that
over and over again you close your eyes
you get uncomfortable position and you
repeat that and you'll find that your
mind will go to that but then it'll go
to thoughts and you just say oh it's in
thoughts and go back to home and you get
to practice it and what after a while
you'll stay in that meditation that
Mantra and then when you're in that
Mantra
um it will then disappear and then you
go into a Transcendent state in other
words you transcend and you're going
basically into your subconscious and
you're in your subconscious and your
subconscious is really what controls you
more than your conscious you know it's
just you're just not conscious of it
because when you're conscious you know
you think oh well what do I want to do
and so on but your subconscious has such
an influence of the things you've
learned in your earlier years or your
genetics or something and they're not
aware from you and when you go down into
that
um you get relief but you also
um help to make the connection between
your subconscious and your conscious and
so when they're aligned you're aligning
your emotional decisions with your
intellectual decisions so I find uh it's
an instinctual thing for me to do what
do I feel emotionally what do I feel
what do I do think about that
intellectually and then how do I
approach that in that calm way it
doesn't diminish your emotions
um uh it just is you feel them
differently and my my love is as much as
it has ever been my um or more maybe
because I feel it differently so I just
want to emphasize it doesn't take away
your emotions or anything it just puts
them in the perspective as though and
you look above yourself and you see
yourself within the life's Arc you see
the strengths and the weaknesses and how
to deal with them and you navigate
better the greatest problem of mankind I
believe wow that's a big statement the
greatest problem of mankind
and it is an exceptional problem at this
moment in time
is people having opinions that they're
stuck on
that
um they won't you know like I have to
have my opinion and that's right and so
on because it prevents them
from
um resolving it up from moving forward
to finding the best answer from
compromising and or doing you know so
like everybody's arguing over everything
and and they and you know they're it's
almost like they're killing each other
and and we're in a society
um you know I have another principle
which is when the causes that you're
behind are more important to you and
others than the system the system is in
Jeopardy so do you are you just
literally going to go fight so here we
are as we think will we fight or we have
or will we have protocols for having
thoughtful disagreements and getting
past them I'm 72 years old I know where
I am in my Ark in life
um the the country has been a tremendous
blessing I've lived the American dream I
know what it's like and I know what my
role is at 72 years old
is to pass along whatever I have that's
of value to others okay so I think the
most important things that I have are
these principles that I wrote down that
work for uh me I put them out you take
them or leave it uh everybody I'm here I
say what I want you people take it or
leave it and then so my
um my goal is to evolve well and to
contribute to Evolution I think that's
the natural thing so at this particular
Point that's that's what I'm trying to
do do you have a pull
okay what's your pull
you know so um yeah it's all in
questions I think it's all in a journey
life is in a journey an adventure that's
why I'm trying to say in principles and
uh for success or you can get by the way
principles
um of any of these principles are also
principles in action is an app that's
available on the I store eyesore and
it's free and it has all of these things
in it but it and so I don't I you know
because we'll we'll separate
um I think people might like that but
you not have to know your pull and then
along the way you're going to have your
adventure and you're going to learn and
then you go through your phases of life
and each phase is different like you
talked about your phase you're in the
middle of your phase in life you talked
about your wife and your relationship
with her okay that is a phase of life
and when you go and by putting it in
perspective it's helpful
um in the back of that book uh
principles for Success there's a life
Arc chart
and if you know where you are on that
life Arc
and you know what the next 10 years is
typically like and you know what you the
people you care about are on their life
arcs you can almost know what's coming
at you and then you could start to think
about it so it's at that level of
knowing yourself and knowing how these
things happen over and over again that
you can achieve your path don't be
surprised most life is this is the same
things that happen over and over again
you're born you probably have parents to
take take care of you maybe you have one
maybe you have two but somebody does
they teach you you have your first phase
of your life where you're dependent on
them and you're learning then you come
out to your second phase of your life
and then you're working and others are
dependent on you and then you have that
so these things happen over and over
again and and you just have to know that
path and know how to approach it have
you
celebrate and embrace successes in your
life too we just spoke about failure I'm
intrigued to know how someone like
yourself deals with success
well I think my Approach my thinking
about success has evolved over a period
of time I I thought about success I
today think about success differently uh
it's like um the way I thought about it
originally when I uh you know you have
this failure uh I thought that it's like
there's a jungle out there I want to
have the great greatest life possible
but in order to be successful I'm can I
have to cross this dangerous jungle now
I could stay on the one side of the
Jungle and have a a boring safe life but
unless I deal with the risks
um risks in return go together and it's
like going into this jungle so what
would I choose would I choose to go into
the jungle and cross the jungle and have
the greatest life possible but I might
get bad things might happen and then I
started to think when I went into that
jungle I of course I had to cross the
jungle but I started to realize how to
cross the jungle most importantly with
people who could see things differently
than I could on the mission with me and
so that and we would protect each other
in that jungle and that's what it was
like so life is a lot like that who are
you in the jungle with and they might
see things differently from you and then
you protect each other and you go
through and the thing that I discovered
was that as I had these successes and
failures and much more successes than
failures I began to realize that I
didn't care as much about the success as
I cared about the journey okay in other
words I didn't want to get out of the
Jungle I didn't want to get to the other
side because it might be like I don't
know climbing mountains or doing
whatever you realize there's a new Peak
and there's a new level of success and
they won't keep you happy okay you you
don't sit there you want to go on yes
and and it is the ups and downs of that
journey and the striving into becoming
better that becomes the new definition
of success and so I started to see my
life in this life Arc way with my
preferences changing because your
preference is naturally change as one
has kids and those they as they start to
think I mean everybody that you're
dealing with is going through into life
Arc if you think about who are the
people you love what is your
relationship with your parents what are
your relationships you have children who
with they will have a life Arc and as
you go through that life Arc and you see
those things changing then you start to
realize that operating consistent with
that life Arc is and on that journey to
evolve well is what success is it's not
yes the money it's like money loses its
marginal utility very quickly right if
you studies of Happiness
um there's a Harvard Professor many
professors I suppose and they tell you
the same thing in terms of studying
happiness around the world there's very
little correlation between how much
money you have in the level of Happiness
past the basic assistance level the
element that there's the highest
correlation with is an element of
community who you're with so it's this
meaningful work are you on a mission and
meaningful relationships through a life
Arc that evolves so that's it my
definition of of success is more like
evolving well and contributing to
evolution I admire
um so many people
um I think the one of the problems we
have today is we don't have Heroes
we don't have role models and heroes
because so many people are interested in
tearing down people
yeah I don't know how we got to that but
it's true I think the the internet
helped helped and social media helped we
need more there were so many great
people role models who could be role
models and I'm and I think
um of just so many in my lifetime that
I've seen let me just
on the thing yes it's the looping and
learning from mistakes
but if another part of it
is the realization that you don't have
to make your decisions in your own head
okay now when you start to realize that
you know what you're good at and what
you're bad at that a power comes to you
when you start to know uh okay who's the
best person to give me the advice or
who's the best person to lead me through
this or when you start to know that you
can go beyond what you think and your
opinionatedness so that you can
triangulate I call it triangulate with
others so that you find three people who
are really
capable of giving you good advice who
will argue with each other and argue
with you so you can see all sides of it
and you work yourself through so it's
not just your eyes looking for the path
but it's other people's eyes looking
with the path with you knowing that
you're going to have uh successes and
failures but that power of that
collective learning and triangulate well
with humbleness is a great power as you
go through that cycle I mentioned that
you believe in the socratic dialogue and
also sort of radical transparency
which is the stress testing of
yeah the culture of Bridgewater that I
learned from these experiences is I'll
say it in one sentence
an idea meritocracy in which the goals
are meaningful work and meaningful
relationships
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency so I want the best ideas to
win out that that's the idea of
meritocracy wherever they come from
I believe in meaningful work and
meaningful relationships reinforcing
each other that they're the greatest
reward and if you have that together
um then you're going to be more
successful if you're on a mission that's
the work you're on then you're on a
mission together and you have that tight
relationship that's a great power but
it's through that Mutual generosity and
Gary and that you have to do that
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency radical truthfulness I mean
um first of all you've got to find out
what's true it's the foundation of
anything so you have to be able to talk
about anything out and get to truth
truth might be what your weaknesses are
as well as what your successes are so it
has that truthfulness and that idea
meritocracy to figure it out and do it
together those are very powerful things
yes I learned that the issues that we're
dealing with like one of the things that
we're trying to do
um my wife uh it does this six days a
week is I'm various ways try to get
um uh programs and things that get high
school kids and eighth and Ninth Grade
to get them through uh high school and
into work
um be in the state of Connecticut okay
um and um I'll give you a statistic it's
a state of Connecticut has uh is one of
the richest States on average but has a
big wealth Gap
um 22 percent of the high school
students are either disengaged or
disconnected disengage means the
absentee rate is greater than 25 in
their failing classes and disconnected
means that they don't know where they
are because they've dropped out of
school in other words more than one in
five students High School is failing and
so
um and they're failing high school and
the budget issues are a problem we I
live in Greenwich Connecticut etiquette
and it's a rich town the average per
student for the for public high school
twenty four thousand dollars it'll go up
the hill and 15 minutes away and um it's
Bridgeport Connecticut it's a poor town
and it's fourteen thousand dollars a
student they need more money because
there's hunger there's
um there's bads conditions they need
more money than Greenwich Connecticut
and yet they're getting significantly
less so what's the natural consequence
of that the parents who are raised onto
these very impossible that kids become
parents and they're raised under these
circumstances and what is their
community and what is their income their
Community is the gangs that because
that's their Community that's the one
they could relate to that and everybody
needs a community and what are their
income it's crime
um in one form or another and there are
gone gangs and shootings all the time
and we're in a situation where of course
that creates not only the crime costs
but it also creates incor high
incarceration costs the state pays 600
million dollars a year for incarceration
so you create a cycle in order to break
that cycle you need everything from
early childhood education all the way
through that yeah and and that has to
make an improvement yeah and that's why
I say you might even need um reforms to
the Constitution because the State
education is a state issue
and in the states they tend to make it a
tax District issue and so there's no way
that you're going to get that now the
cost of that bad education is immense
for the country because not only is is
it unfair but also you don't know where
the talent is going to come from
throughout history you find that the
most talented people can come from
anywhere and and there's only basic
things you need to have what I had when
I was growing up I was very lucky I had
two parents who cared for me that were
good guidance I went to a public school
and I came out to a a country of equal
opportunity so I could work hard and
that was it
um and we need to I think in one way or
another
um establish that there's a bottom that
nobody can go below and to realize that
those are good Investments the same is
true for infrastructure
um there's
um no uh inadequate infrastructure My
Generation has given the Next Generation
a lot of debt a broken down education
system and a broken down infrastructure
so that's going to require a lot so my
general reaction is philanthropy is
woefully inadequate
and anything that I have I haven't done
you're saying like you have to no I'm a
dumb oh you're a dumb in other words
that what I mean is
that any success I've had in my life has
been do more due to my knowing how to
deal with what I don't know then what
you can do to anything I know
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Warren Buffett
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there how can other
people tap dance to work what's the
secret of that you find your passion you
find your passion I was very very lucky
to find out you know when I was uh seven
or eight years old and fortunately my
children have found their passion my you
know one son